is no particularly good way to frame
what's happening now for the toy party
but you could argue that Rishi c-neck
has a slight Advantage here because he
lost a leadership election last year
basically on this theme on this idea of
fairy tales and the fact that you just
cannot over promise because you will
severely disappoint which was a good
thing to bring up in the week of when
those trust took power last year and the
49 days that followed he is able to make
this case people didn't want to hear it
last year still not totally sure they
want to hear it this year but it does
seem that going into party conferences
and this idea of long-termism is going
to be a theme for him and his government
looking at what needs to be done for the
next 10 to 15 years It's A Hard Sell to
your party because it it's not
necessarily going to win you the next
election but it is totally necessary for
the country to get back on track